22 months ago December the 4th my
husband Dennis parks Hill passed away
he was 29 years old I was eight months
pregnant with our first child so
thinking about his future and and how we
had just ruined it before we ever
started you know and I was just hopeless
we win in the emergency and she stopped
walking citizen I can't walk anymore
[Music]
somehow she knew that uh maybe she
wasn't gonna make it and she did this
for me did this for me I struggled with
alcohol I struggled with a solitude
tried to get away from it all there was
definitely something missing in my life
everyone is going through something
that's happened so how are you going to
deal with that
when a real-estate market went bust in
the 1980s Ramsay and his family faced
bankruptcy we made a crucial mistake
that cost everything we spent the next
two and a half years losing everything
we owned we were foreclosed and bankrupt
and scared out of our mind
we clawed our way out I mean we drove
old beat-up cars we wore consignment
sale clothes we don't buy anything we
don't pay for we live on a written plan
every month we always keep an emergency
fund I mean we got the devil knocked out
of us the storms are gonna come but
they're not gonna kill you
you will get through this all of a
sudden we were back together on a
crusade there are a lot of sacrifices
that we had to make hard work a lot of
dedication I don't ever want to feel
this way again I'm not afraid anymore
this is what it's all about this is what
we work for I have what it takes and now
is the time to do it nobody owns me
anymore
nobody what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is never giving
up
[Music]
just over five years ago we discovered
that we needed help stress with money
had become increasing in our family we
were living in a house too big with
three cars I had recently lost you know
my job through the banking crisis when
our daughter was born Courtney had to go
on basically a home rest and she had to
quit her job she was born she had an eye
condition and required surgery she was
born blind and by a miracle God has
completely healed her her vision is
perfect
we were just scraping by trying to keep
things afloat
I was working pizza delivery
you know trying to just make some ends
meet while I was looking for for
full-time work at that time Blake was
diagnosed with cancer when Nolan was six
months old it was just an awakening we
had personal loan student loans
increasing credit card debt just trying
to keep meals on the table a mortgage we
were trying to keep afloat I mean it was
just normal
[Music]
[Music]
so I had this little financial ministry
at my church in the evenings I was doing
some financial teaching and some
one-on-one coaching counseling but my
full-time day job was real estate during
the days I was part of a real estate
Club in town and we occasionally we
bring in an outside speaker to talk to
us to help us build up our membership we
needed to promote one of these speakers
that was coming in and I knew a guy that
had a local radio show on a little local
station here in Nashville who was doing
a bad really bad a top radio show and I
talked the guy and let me come on the
air we kind of got done talking about
that and he's like so what are you doing
these days and I said well I'm helping
people over at my church stop
foreclosures and help them with their
budgets and that kind of stuff as a
ministry it's kind of cool I'm fun with
it and he goes hey if anybody out there
is having trouble just call in and the
phone rang and some guy came on that was
about to lose his car and I walked him
through how to negotiate with the bank
on a repo and then another phone call
came in another phone call and then they
the hour was not before we knew it and
he we got through and he's like hey that
light was really cool we don't get phone
calls can you come back and so I went
back down just for the fun of it
I was driving towards Nashville to go
look at a real estate deal and the phone
rang in my car and a guy named Roy was
on the other line
it was a friend of mine that was in the
insurance business he goes hey that guy
quit that radio show we had to go do
that show yes I'm doing radio man
there's no money in radio and he goes
hey we'll go down there and do it I'll
do it a couple days a week you do it a
couple days a week so we kept talking
about it finally I called the station
and found the manager a guy named David
Manning I had a visit one day mr. Ramsey
came walking in sat down Dave started
talking another thing I could hear from
Dave was that black left left left left
left I'll do it for free
blehh blehh blehh blehh blehh blehh you
know I'll do it for free and that really
caught my attention of what we were
wanting to do is some local programming
and Dave had a great idea of great
concepts so you know I said Dave must go
for it we started June 29th of 1992 for
free Dave did it and Dave did it right
except for that music he played an
opening them Tuffy just drove me crazy
it's time to clip those cards dump that
debt and start those savings it's the
money game with your host Dave Ramsey
author and financial counselor and Roy
Matlock the financial expert it's a show
designed to help you prepare for your
financial future our message was not a
money show for rich people it was a
money show for everyone the point being
that anyone can handle money well and if
anyone handles money well they'll have
more I loved helping people fix this
problem in their life and the phone rang
from day one I'm not very good at
handling money I don't know how put
together a budget and get back on your
feet and get other employment I tell you
what discs are so sweet it's just beer
we were looking for and people who build
wealth are the ones that control the guy
in the mirror call me Monday and tell me
you didn't buy the car okay
i'ma hold you accountable man okay all
right be good I was in terrible street
and I was living in the projects and I
listened to your show and today I own
two pieces of property and I'm in a much
much better financial position I've paid
off a lot of debt I love it Frye's
people in the project listen to you I
hope so they've had the highest rating
show that we did have the only thing
that we didn't have was the financial
backing
the next thing that happened was Gaylord
bought the radio station out of chapter
11 bankruptcy we wanted to promote wwt n
as a lifestyle radio station that we
could gear some conservative talk and
sports and entertainment of course the
last thing that was on my mind was a
financial show seven three seven nine
nine eight six if you want to talk about
money that's what we're here for and I
listened to the money game a few times
and I thought well it's basic but it's
it's just straightforward and it's
things that people could understand
financial planners tell us we need to
have three to six months of our personal
expenses grandma said have money for a
rainy day because sometimes it rains and
grandma was a financial genius as far as
that part goes my name is Ken Cosette
everybody calls me Duker live here in
beautiful Las Hill Alaska as home my
whole philosophy was credit cards I'll
just work another week swipe the card
work another week swipe the card I got
this right I was living paycheck to
paycheck went down in lower 48 I see my
buddy in Grand Rapids and the course of
that I blew up my motorcycle my 95
Heritage Softail so I was sitting in
hotel room and trying to figure out how
I was gonna get back to work I made a
decision I need to get a rental car I
was gonna run a car to drive back anyway
so I'm sitting there looking at my
wallet I got these credit cards everyone
on the maxed out so I call a credit card
company and I'm begging the gal on the
other end of the phone to extend me
another thousand dollars in limits like
it
which was $25,000 i maxed out all of
them so January 7th of 2013 and I still
carry to this day I will carry to my
grave is my debts sat down I wrote them
all out
[Music]
January 7 2013
BAM there it is
house dead
[Music]
$395,000
[Music]
today we're alike
[Music]
I did it as our station grew the Dave
Ramsey show really became a very
integral part and we just saw a lot of
people really getting into Dave's
message we found that there was a whole
lot of people that were listening not
just because they were broke they were
listening for financial advice and it
created a following in a sense we're
teaching people how to live their lives
well and if they do the right things if
they plant the right seed in the ground
crop that they harvest and their life is
gonna be positive rather than weeds I
could tell he had great goals for this
program and he had a tremendous vision
of where he wanted this to go so I sat
down with all of the people from the
radio station I told them we want to be
brush Limbaugh and these people looked
at me like this guy is off his rocker
we were killing and we were crushing it
and we had the range we were actually
beating rush limbaugh we couldn't
believe that I was like some little kid
that didn't know how to play actually
sold more records than Elvis
we're making good money for the station
which gave us the basis to begin to
syndicate and we thought okay I need a
producer and that's when I hired Blake
Thompson
I wouldn't met Dave he did the interview
and he said man I think you're the guy
first impression of Blake is he's
extremely likable he's not a hyper
aggressive type person and he was
working for one one thing I realized the
first five minutes with Dave was this
guy is on fire he has a destiny or a
goal or something that he's going for
and there was no doubt about it he was
one of those instantly ders where you
want to jump on the train because he's
driving and it really felt at the time
this is an opportunity
[Music]
remember sitting in Gaylord boardroom at
Blake on his first day we went in there
and said hey we want to syndicate it
would take a nationwide and we had the
program director we had the GM of the
whole cluster of WSM wtn in there we had
the chief engineer that been there like
40 years engineer started telling us how
it couldn't happen it couldn't happen
well I've already got these stations
signed up it's got to happen and I you
know I got mad and I just slapped my
hand down on the table and I said you
know what you guys an engineering don't
understand is he and I pointed Bob Meyer
signed a contract that says that we're
gonna syndicate this show out of here so
whether you help or whether you don't we
are going to launch this did I think he
was crazy no did I think he was biting
off more than he could chew at the time
a little bit they understood that we
were not going to accept no as a
possible answer and then I looked at
Blake and I pointed at him and I said
and my producer is gonna make it happen
I went home that night and told my wife
I think Dave thinks I'm smarter than I
am or that I I knew more about
broadcasts than I do because I was
clueless you know oddly enough they
figured it out and we're back we're
talking money how long have you been
saving money Dave Ramsey hits the
Nashville airwaves each week with advice
for middle Tennesseans on how to handle
their money show kept growing and kept
adding stations we added Spokane
Washington Las Vegas and then Jackson
Mississippi
then these companies the company that
Roy work for said look every time you
add a state that's a whole nother front
we have to go fight for you on and even
though Roy was making serious money
selling insurance mutual funds for these
guys they said look you have to choose
if you wanna work for us you can't be on
the air it was real painful for Roy and
for me we've been friends a long time
and he made the decision to quit the
show then we began to do the money game
with Dave Ramsey
[Music]
by then bill Hampton had come on board
and was helping us try to syndicate the
show so I was moving to Nashville from
Atlanta in July of 1995 and flipping
radio stations
came across this guy talking about money
spend every dollar on paper before the
month begins is what you always do with
the budget and at the time I was broken
thinking a lot about money I couldn't
figure out why I was broke everything
the guy said made sense to me every
dollar of our income has a name on this
paper so I kept listening all the way to
Nashville pulled the u-haul truck into
my apartment in Antioch went upstairs
picked up the phone and called Dave
Ramsey on the radio he said I tell you
what come onto my Financial Peace
University class and I went out met Dave
and that was it
bill Hampton came on he really took over
that whole okay how are we gonna grow
this thing how we gonna get in other
markets what are things that we're doing
now that have to change I came in and
sat down with Dave and he said I'd love
for you to come and run my radio
division and I said Dave I have no idea
how the signal gets from the studio to
the car and he said that's exactly why I
want you because if you were a career
radio guy you wouldn't believe we could
accomplish what I'm getting ready to
tell you I want to accomplish you
believe in what we're doing you believe
in me and you know how to promote things
in 1999 when I came on we had 25
stations we were syndicated but it was
pretty small not any major major markets
or anything but we were starting the
process of growing and really putting a
lot of effort into growing our stations
the money game was big in town but if
you asked someone in New York or LA
Money game really didn't make a lot of
sense
somebody said look rush doesn't do the
Republican game dr. Laura doesn't do the
relationship game these people just put
their names on the show and people
identify with that the money game you
know officially became the Dave Ramsey
show we immediately jumped into where
it's the Dave Ramsey show it's about
life love and relationships and how they
happen to revolve around money there was
more to it than just wanting to be a big
name
was how many people can we help
[Music]
when we first got married finances was
my deal and it had always been my deal
it's something I enjoyed I loved the
spreadsheets I loved the data Lisa
really didn't care one way or another at
least that from my point of view that's
what it felt like
shortly after we were married our first
son Sean was born while we were in the
hospital the nurses kept bringing him
saying he wouldn't stop crying it turned
out after a couple of years we found out
that he indeed had autism and our
journey with sean began and it was a
challenging one as Sean became more
independent we started to see our
marriage start to drop away the marriage
had gotten so bad that we were living in
different rooms in the house I struggled
with with guilt and I struggled with
alcohol and struggled with pornography
and I struggled with solitude tried to
get away from it all there was
there was definitely something missing
in my life I was playing the credit card
shuffle game I was shuffling no payments
doing all this stuff and realized that
was one of the biggest stressors in my
life I was a little hesitant when Scott
came home and told me about it FDU and
asked me to join the people that were
sharing their debt-free screams and the
relationships that people were we're
talking about was what I wanted in my
relationship our driving force is that
person on the other hand a single mom
that couple young couple the struggling
with her marriage that old couple who's
worried about retirement that this
person is losing their home this person
who's about to do something stupid
it's gonna cost them the next decade of
their life to recover and I've been that
guy I don't want that to happen to you
at the end of the day we had one real
station it was 99 seven wtn right here
in Nashville massive FM signal
the problem was Nashville backed them
was perceived to be a lot different than
Nashville is today no one gave Nashville
any credibility and so it didn't matter
that we were the number one show on a
massive station it was in Nashville and
that got zero credibility in the talk
radio world he seemed like every single
station we added was scratching and
clawing we knew he was changing lives we
knew he was helping people
we heard the emotion on the air and so
we just had to get people to buy into
that there was no respect because we
weren't corporate owned all the
corporate owned things got the big slick
push and because none of them owned us
some people assumed that we weren't any
good because if we were any good they
would have bought us having one of Rush
Limbaugh's producers say you'll never
make it as independent you'll never make
it probably made Dave more determined
than ever
even though Dave was offered to become
one of those and be bought for some good
money there was an any amount that he
was going to take he wanted us to own it
he wanted us to grow it and whatever we
ran into in the future that was just
part of it not only were we fighting
Radio affiliates and program directors
we were fighting a hole in a financial
industry we attacked this with a passion
because it was more than just a radio
show and people didn't get that even
though we had all of this animosity
going on around this show one thing that
honestly has kept us going all these
years for the listeners as people were
calling people wanted to know Dave's
advice they trusted him he built that
kind of trust my wife and I are
recovering from a prescription drug
induced gambling and shopping addiction
that I had I lost my job and I'm so
behind on everything pretty freakin
scary yeah I've been there
I'm scared I'm going to lose my house
I'm currently disabled and in default in
student loans to the tune of one hundred
and seven thousand dollars no matter
what was going on the radio and
financial industry the listener was the
number one goal it was truly a David and
Goliath story in a lot of ways because
you had the fear of being David but we
also said God is on our side and if God
be for us who can be against us we were
called to help people and not just in
one city or called to take people this
message on how to win with money how to
win at life
[Music]
the first thing that drew me to my
husband his size and his heart
everything that he did it was for his
family helping others but it was for his
family too
[Music]
he gave me hope
he gave me love he gave me spirit he
gave me faith we were a good team before
when Dennis was here we needed to change
the dynamic after Dennis passed away she
was the one paying bills he communicated
with me and I communicate with him but I
was thinking well you know he's got it I
don't have to worry about numbers
because he's better than than me on it
but what what was the crash point it was
when he passed away I I needed to be in
charge of everything
I felt the heaviness of the financial
situation because I didn't have my
provider anymore and I didn't have my
protector anymore I became the protector
the provider for the kids
all the goals that we set together I
still have it and I'm gonna do it
I need to for ahem for me for the kids
for our family I'm gonna find a way I
don't care I have the goal I find a way
I'm gonna do it I would get so angry
because we lose a radio station that
means a single mom it's listening to me
that was getting helped there's now
getting some crap show in the afternoon
instead of getting that help you take me
off the air that means that nobody's
there for them and man I'm passionate
about this I believe this stuff we knew
that we couldn't compete with the other
radio shows head-to-head on credibility
or on money and so we knew we had to
beat them other ways we had to beat them
with what we were best at which was
relationships affiliate relations was a
phrase that was in the industry it's
always been in the industry the strange
thing was it was an oxymoron no one did
it they just had affiliates and they
told them what to do they bullied them
they pushed them around so a lot of
stations carry the show and hated the
people that they had to work with to
carry the show and we thought well
that's an easy one to be all we had to
do is be likable and help them sell the
show
no one ever helped them make money on
the show after they put it on the air he
had this vision for a position that no
one else in the radio industry had ever
even thought to create and to this day
no one has he said your full-time job is
going to be building relationships with
our radio stations you're gonna know
their birthdays their spouses birthdays
you're gonna know their favorite sports
team you're gonna know what makes them
tick and you're gonna have such a
relationship with them that they won't
drop the show that part changed the game
I think that's something most stations
don't get most affiliates don't have and
that's very appealing to have she really
began to develop relationships with
these affiliates
they love talking and working with her
it just made it fun that was our secret
weapon once we would finally get
somebody on board like that team super
served a radio station at a level that
was unprecedented and still is to this
day
we always built those relationships in a
way that they knew they could trust us
we were constantly showing them how we
were delivering content that was so
different from anyone else changing
people's lives
we just kept telling them the story over
and over and over again the show was
growing when we were still doing our
regular Radio affiliate growth and then
we were approached by Fox News that they
were starting a new sister channel and
wanted to do an actual television show
came out with Fox Business in the
evening it was the number one show and
their goal was to draw a younger
audience and a female audience and money
on Main Street was their theme in those
days we want to do money for regular
people what was crazy was for some
reason in the radio industry we gained
so much more clout just for having that
affiliation they saw the ads Dave
Ramsey's on Fox Business now and is like
well he's legitimate now you're like
okay had influential people watching in
the major media market it gave Dave
tremendous exposure we definitely saw it
open new opportunities we definitely saw
that we were getting better radio
stations in larger markets it helped
lift the brand television is powerful
people putting the groceries on the
plastic does this take an extra bite out
of your wallet welcome to answer that
question Dave Ramsey's here Dave Ramsey
is making his list and he is checking it
twice we welcome back a man who I think
should simply declare victory Dave Ryan
[Music]
after Fox Business we stayed with what
we do the best and let's indicate in
that show and grow in the show it was at
the 300 mark where it felt like we
couldn't be ignored anymore just kept
growing and growing more affiliates so
we got up to the 500 mark
the show itself was growing it's big
every kind of knows it now but it still
comes down to the listener and it comes
down to them actually doing the
day-to-day work making those good
decisions and then reaching their goals
and getting there they did it we all we
did was put it out there
i sat down tonight cut up my credit
cards I hate them things I just did just
what they said we had to make sacrifices
we didn't purchase new things we didn't
go out to eat when it was wintertime the
house was cold and when it was
summertime the house was hot we fight in
every space were in we hustle and grind
in every space were in because it gives
us that opportunity and to transfer that
crusade to that person on the other end
as we're going through FPU our kids
started to see this stuff all of a
sudden we were back together on a
crusade having come through the whole
process got amount of debt gone through
cancer having a budget having life
insurance we're free we can look up now
and see out we can start looking towards
you know the future and start realizing
some of the dreams that we have
[Music]
I've known from day one that it was much
much bigger than a radio show we are the
only talk radio show where life change
is even a factor our content changes
people's lives it seemed all of a sudden
although it had been a difficult couple
of years we were debt-free and Scott
came to me and said what do you think
about going to Nashville and being on
Dave's show and I thought what better
way to celebrate and share what we've
done with other people where do you two
live
Irvine California uh-uh good Southern
California what it brings you to
Tennessee obviously to do our debt-free
screen well worth the trip all the way
across the continent the debt-free
stream was born as a happy accident a
woman just called in and was so excited
that she paid off her debt she said I
want to scream it and she just screamed
I'm debt free this was so emotional this
was so big the way she built it up and
screamed I'm debt free that Dave just
decided hey when you reach this I want
you to call in and tell us it's you
screaming
you're here to do your debt-free scream
all the way from Alaska
yes sir I'm hoping they hear it up there
today this is something going on here
there's something visceral that's
happening something emotional spiritual
that's happening these people lives
there at a point in their journey a
point in their story where they need to
celebrate they've been on the hustle and
grind they work the extra jobs they've
sold stuff they need to celebrate the
fact that they won and this shows always
been about them winning so how much debt
have you paid off Cynthia $60,000 eighty
nine thousand eighty thousand dollars
three hundred ninety four thousand
dollars good lord
it's a felt need that almost everyone
has and there's no one else speaking to
it every listener out there that is
listen to Dave applied the principles
and changed their life I would bet you
has done it for something far larger for
them 22 months ago December the 4th 2012
my husband Dennis Barksdale passed away
he listened to you every day and he
wanted to leave a legacy for his kids
the final goal the weight off her
shoulders
like freedom encourages other people
that guy can do it I can do it if that
person flew from Seattle to Nashville to
do it that free scream maybe maybe it's
important that pay the price to enter
you know I'm about out of energy and I
need to tired and I need to fight
through during your class I got life
insurance he's ordered my wife and just
six months after that I was diagnosed
with cancer
oh my Lauren FOMA so during the process
of the last five years we bought it
three times and was able to pay for it
and still get out of debt so it can't be
done for those out there listening it's
possible yeah we didn't carry any
medical debt we cash floated all three
times it kind of helped people keep
going it helped people believe they
could actually do it because other
people were doing it it really became
our theme for our show at that point
halfway through or so we're making about
thirty six thousand and then started a
business yeah and it's the last year we
made 72 with that jawed really saved our
marriage and just made our family so
much richer and we feel so blessed I
mean how do you listen to a family talk
about being in hundreds of thousands of
dollars in debt how do you hear about a
husband and wife who are everyday
fighting their marriage is falling apart
the kids are seeing that and they didn't
think they had any hope having been
through what we went through with our
relationship where for two years we
argued out right in front of our
children I was very very concerned about
the impact that that had had I learned
quite a bit about my parents the biggest
thing was just the example they were
able to be to us as we were starting our
marriage we were receiving light and it
was shining through us and now they're
standing in the lobby of financial peace
Plaza and that family is united and that
marriage is stronger than ever
and they yell together I'm debt free I
mean that gets me every time driving
down the road I cry like a baby
the ones that come in with the kids that
are young and the parents explain what
they've accomplished I still to this day
get choked out and I'm going man you
have no idea how this probably changed
your world right after he passed away I
just said the goal for me and the kids
to be there free and today we are here
we paid off the house after 22 months
your house it was our dream
Venice's and mine to make this happen
and and God is really good shows not
about getting out of that shows about
having your money well getting out of
debts part of the journey is all that's
what the debt-free screen is become it's
become the celebration count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
[Music]
proverb says Hope deferred makes the
heart sick I've been there most people
have been there at some point
the problem with hopelessness is you
don't take the steps to win because you
don't believe they're gonna work you
will never engage in a weight-loss
program if you don't think it's gonna
work
you will never engage in different
behaviors in your marriage if you don't
think it's gonna work you will never
change the way you're treating your kids
if you don't think it's gonna have a
positive result you will never go back
and forgive someone if you don't think
it's gonna have a positive result you
will not change the way you handle your
money and get out of debt if you don't
think it's gonna work
the interesting thing about the rest
that proverb Hope deferred makes the
heart sick and it says when desire comes
when desire comes when the hope comes
back it is the tree of life that says
how important hope is when you have that
it propels you to take the steps that
cause you to win
[Music]
we started this process five years ago
we could only focus on here on our needs
our budget our life
one of the biggest motivators for us
getting out of debt was being able to go
and do what God is calling us to do when
you're in debt and you're a slave to the
payments going out every month you don't
have the freedom if he says go so now
having that freedom in our budget in our
life and our marriage and just being
open to serve wherever we can to help
others it's just it's huge to have it
where nobody owns me anymore
nobody except God just puts you in a
whole new level of living it's been
nothing but windfall since and you've
given more than we ever imagined yeah we
shared I knit and I was determined but I
didn't know how much I just felt so
happy I felt excited I felt relief I
felt powerful I did it we have gone into
every space we go into and we've been
the underdog we've been on the David and
Goliath and we can't quit because
there's someone out there that needs our
help but if we surrender to the problems
of Corporate America owning a space or
the lies that are told about us if we
surrender to that that means someone on
the other end of that is not getting
helped and so we don't have the option
to quit there's too many lives too many
destinies too many family trees being
changed on the other side of it
hope is a powerful thing and it has been
our privilege to connect that to our
audiences for 25 years
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how can
we help you